as of today  oscorp industries has surpassed quest  aerospace as the principal supplier to  the united states military  in short ladies and gentlemen of the  board  costs are down  revenues are up  and our stock has never been higher  wonderful news norman wonderful as a  matter of fact it's the reason we're  selling the company  what yes quest aerospace is  recapitalizing in the wake of the  bombing  expanding  they made a tender offer we can't ignore  why wasn't i told the last thing they  want is a power struggle with entrenched  management  the deal is off if you come with it  the board expects your resignation in 30  days  but you can't do this to me  i started this company  you know how much i sacrificed  oh max please norman  the board is unanimous  we're announcing the sale after the  world unity festival  i'm sorry  you're out norman  where am i  you